[Applause]
[Music]
most concentrated I've been in the
classroom my entire life being a levy up
in the office - rabbit rabbit water -
corporation talk about ownership and
leverage 1800 sectors out there beverage
I have nothing to say all of the visual
speaks but people complaining my gums
look just compounded when gets different
contact I was always expecting that's me
that was neither student this one right
here that's how I roll it's real nice
little Indian what can I say sorry
and what can I say Michael we are
overjoyed have you Jay King every time I
see you come here I ask myself don't you
have anything to do don't you have
anything to do with your money sometimes
I keep telling them if I because have so
much it because of compassion for
somebody else
let me remind you that you have this
most fulfilling in a doctor more than
government that is the man who have
build more school buildings not abused
even the capital you are building
mortgages we have the 13:1 of life and
we are clinical people
exactly I want to give you a mature
never ever think that whatever I have
done J it just for the sake of it
believe you are so in the week for a new
generation done in other words would
have no choice I don't know chance of a
returns in life because my marital as -
a
exactly right the anti-establishment my
name again
what you have a date you what I don't
attend I'm given the opportunity for
these young ones to have a shot at life
because in this world without education
your chances are almost zero or becoming
anything
[Music]
just perspective and it's just
perspective so it is also a short story
I wanted to read aloud okay seven neck
Jessie firmly yet named Jessie yeah yet
ship it's done out of love
and the club cafe black a lesbian catchy
laughing that she told a Senate the
Senate last Senate we have learned a lot
from you they're coming up do it it is
important that that people in the
community also played a role in building
I wish it for breakfast how do you think
he knows that think that's
[Music]
we didn't just ask them you contribute
on Mondays we folder the Arcana and
cilia legs and then developability
they sweated on top of the involving
[Music]
picking up the tasty rocks how do I
stand strong I think the working with
the dirt was no question I think my
favorite part is ultra I genuinely think
we were on the high side of enthusiasm
of work as a group
[Music]
none of our production your moment is
almost always begin the field of MAG
Java project are taking a year black and
the molecule Academy any better
[Music]
like maybe one life one life one life
one life one with the bun or something
saying that yes they roll another one
okay
we don't have water in fact we don't
even have any particular object we don't
have any help of drinking if anybody can
fix now we have to travel them seven
miles or so to get the nearest of data
that education is the bedrock of
everything I am a student of a guru
multi-planet the data of my friends
where is your legacy
what do you want to human metal it is
people that build book it is before that
that that servo home so while we keep
education to our people we are giving
them the key to doing the rest of the
day which is the health care push the
road and everything do you want to be
remembered as a caring and responsible
period do you want to be amendment of
the committed system do you want to be
remembered as an advocate in students or
do you want to amendment as a patristic
city was and how do you want to be
remembered for the war shows that's one
of whiskey or time you are not wasted
reinventing this is the best use of the
money and the time and I believe other
people that produce bonds are you should
understand a little boy from attacking
day that was showing so much is
developing what a joy to know that what
you have done together with me if you
get our bodies evolved and the community
and Cal can do better than in the future
that is all that is this
always thank you very much I'm safe
everybody education I've no replacement
we cannot use education as an
alternative to anything that is the only
choice you have inaudible and thank you
for taking one life what an amazing
experience got a plan for you such a
worry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
michael ii for you a season and fill the
sky happy you society and but I'm
swinging you know I you can't
[Music]
can I
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
he is the last welcome means this math
means I mean Zambian philosophy or the
mean queen although that's not the first
time I've heard that
headed to the oh wait in his wheel here
Airport amazing her from Ghana plainly
the apps just dropped I've been up since
4:00 a.m. destroying it on Twitter Brian
is finally everybody's height he's
sitting on the floor
it's a giant great trip very crew crew
say hello they don't follow directions
really well nobody fickle love but
amazing trip and can't wait to be home
the board with wheels dancer said who
the hell knows what this thing's doing
the right things and then on the
over-the-shoulder
double tasking when the apps pictures as
you can play on the apps and looking at
pictures for the mag on a trip for those
videos them out which what
[Music]